guess who's back guess who's back guess
who's back
oh no what I asked you guys to send me
topics to talk about somebody's I send
me some weird [ __ ] they're talking about
a monkey that [ __ ] himself in the
[ __ ] but anyways let's get into this
now for those of you who don't know
recently there has been a hundred and
forty million dollar settlement for the
kids who are forced to eat semen cookies
by their teacher that's right you heard
me right semen cookies this one now how
did you get caught you ask well in 2012
a pharmacy employee called the cops when
the teacher brought in bondage style
photos of children for them to develop
so let me get this straight not only are
you a Sikh free you've done this [ __ ]
get tell me right now that you could not
develop those photos somewhere else
besides your local right age it is 2014
that [ __ ] on your iPad [ __ ] damn how
are you going to put physical evidence
of your sick ass crime and wonder how
you got caught by robbing a house and
leaving a semen trail on the doorstep
well how do you know it's in see that
come drops you know what the sad thing
about all this is that throughout the
early 90s this man was accused of
masturbating in front of the children
multiple times but the district is
starting to ignore it okay let's be real
for a second how do you ignore kids tell
you that a saggy balls old man was
beaten his dick like a soda machine with
loose change you now in the worst case
is gonna say one of these kids was a
habitual liar
but even if he or she was don't you
think that some weird [ __ ] my Jimmy Hall
is full today well no the teacher was
beaten up I read the outfit [ __ ]
fake my date with mom well [ __ ] I would
give them the benefit of the doubt
now man that was even documented photos
of kids eating chocolate chip cookies
with slime on it
what more do you need now to me it seems
like this is just another sad story of a
bunch of people looking out for their
jobs rather than the kids because
according to multiple articles when a
parent tells you that there
do something about this and call the
police and your response is Li's don't
call the cops
it'll be further proof that you do not
give two shits about these kids that are
supposed to matter in your line of work
they just never forget that when parents
drop off their kids at the school they
do that expecting their kids to be safe
they actually entrust their children to
the staff and their legal guardian and
expect to do what's best for the kids
while they are on campus now because
nothing was done when it should have
been dealt with now we're at a lose-lose
situation now for Florida I'm going to
sue the individual that will do sue the
school district for a hundred and forty
million dollars one hundred and forty
million dollars on education gun and now
these kids aren't fit for the rest of
their lives
now after all this is said and done that
man was sentenced to about 25 years in
prison and at his age that's basically
for the rest of his life do I personally
think that's fair because in all honesty
I have to put myself in the shoes of
those parents or even the kids and the
punishment does not fit the crime now
I'm not sure if this is legal but every
day he should be forced to drink a
bucket uptempo seaman with some dry ass
cookies and no got that milk that's
right she just got real mother nice to
nice to know ya know yeah yes I'm back
for this Sunday I almost missed this
video but I got my ass back from Hawaii
and the moment I came back I started
work you wanted work yeah but remember
every Sunday there's going to be a video
and during the week I'm going to
sprinkle a few videos here and there too
so stay tuned for that always check to
you two for my updates because I'm gonna
be posting follow me on instagram follow
me on twitter follow me
oh what's that other one not since
credit Twitter yeah and some other stuff
you see me there final final final but I
love you guys next Sunday and you guys
will see you April maybe you're funny
best-fit maybe you guys might see some
other box check it out stay tuned I will
see y'all later
hahaha boom box puppets oh [ __ ] forgot
to turn love this window don't want to
disturb the peace it's only for the
proof that you do not give two shits
about these kids that are